you know there are two movies now i have
the answers and nobody else does
denis told me i'm blade runner because i
look inside of harrison ford's mind
i'm the only person that knows if he's
the replicant or not so he said that i
can decide
so i have that secret now and now with
this movie
i have the secret to carry as well
[Music]
the thin red line wow it brings back
memories
uh just hearing that name i think about
terence malik
um who is you know a genius
and you know he's a guy who made two
movies and disappeared for
20 years which you just gotta respect
you know you gotta respect anybody that
just like yeah
i'm gonna go off and and you know pursue
some other interests and
kind of just live life i mean i took
about six years off
but i think 20 is like that's that's
real
i can't say i took six years off i was i
was doing other things i was on tour
mostly but
but terence malik is you know he's made
two of my favorite films
um uh well many more than two but
two of the the seminal films that he
made one is called badlands the other
one's called days of heaven
both like you know must-watch films for
cinephiles and actors and actually i
remember the audition
for that and uh it was
maybe the worst audition i ever had they
i walked in the casting office and they
had like a desk
turned on its side and we were supposed
to kind of like
shoot you know imaginary bullets at each
other and pretend to be in a war
which i guess makes sense if you're
auditioning for a war movie but
i just couldn't do it i don't know i
just couldn't get with the program
and i stood up in the middle of the
audition and you know
got sprayed by a thousand imaginary
bullets and i just stopped and i said i
i just can't i didn't i just felt too
embarrassed
i was probably just too naive as an
actor to pull that off in that room you
know maybe i just wasn't you know good
enough or something but
but i stopped in the middle of the
audition which is unheard of
and i and i actually just i i tapped out
i said i can't do this i i'm not your
guy
and uh for some reason or another
terence malik called me up and i think
we had met
actually before that just caught him on
a general meeting
and he wanted me to play this part in
the movie
we're going to tackle breasts through
platoon and reserve
we gotta cross those three folds of
ground you see
once we get beyond that we gotta attack
that hill and the part that he wanted me
to play was to be the first person to
die
and he said well if i cast you
and you die really early on
then everyone watching the movie is
gonna know that no one's safe
uh so that that was i don't know if he
was just kind of you know
being nice but that was you know
the role was important for him
when i was on set there were these
little like uh
leaves that if you touch them these
plants they
they would close up and i i can't
remember it was me or another character
i was right there we were we were right
near the camera as i can't remember it
was my character someone else was dying
i just remember he saw one of those
leaves near
the frame and he was like you know just
reach out now touch the leave
and it closed as the character was dying
and then he went and shot
extreme like macro close-ups of the
plant or something
i don't know if it's in the final film
but um
i just remember you know how aware he
was of his surroundings of nature
[Music]
fight club i remember
when there was this rumor going around
that they were making this
really controversial book
into a movie and
david fincher was directing and there
was a time there like i didn't realize
it was just a year after thin red line
but there was a time there where there
was there were really special
films like kind of really edgy films
that were challenging
these you know a tour type directors
that were just doing some incredible
work so
it was one that i really wanted to be a
part of and i i
i lobbied to be a part of and i remember
bleaching my hair
and my eyebrows white we did one pass
and i think it was brad pitt was like
um said something about billy idol
you know he was like blonder you know so
we went we went
even wider with it i really enjoyed
being on that set
because i got to watch uh brad
who's incredibly loose and
and naturalistic you know always does
something a little different
take to take and that was interesting to
see and everybody on it just kind of
felt like we were
you know kind of getting into trouble
and doing you know something that was
potentially special but
you know on the darker side of the
universe yeah working with venture was
just a dream
did you train a lot in fighting and
prepare your body
no i don't think we rehearsed very much
at all from from my memory
and it was supposed to be like you're
fighting like you would you would fight
not like a professional fighter i should
say like the character would fight
[Applause]
the only thing that wasn't real is we
weren't actually hitting each other but
you did get hit
at times you know it was it wasn't like
it was perfectly
choreographed you know it was all it was
really
is as real fake as you could get um
those fights were you know people were
throwing each other all over the place
but um it was a good one man it was
really exciting
it's under control sir
where's tyler sir the first rule of
project mayhem is you do not
have the prosthetics at the end
something i had never done before i
think it was the first time that i've
worn prosthetics
i remember getting super claustrophobic
i fell asleep while they put this big
life cast on me made out of plaster
i fell asleep and then for like two
minutes and then woke up and i was
inside this thing and i didn't know
where i
was so i like started ripping it off
running down the street and
uh had a full-on just claustrophobic uh
attack
yeah i avoid those those they're called
life casts i avoid those to this day
requiem for a dream yeah requiem for a
dream was
it's a big one for me uh personally and
you know made such a big impact in my
life and my
career it was just the 20th anniversary
which is really hard to believe
i i was talking with darren aronofsky
about it and we just were like wait
did someone get the dates wrong this is
just impossible
but yeah a life-changing experience i
remember we knew that like there was
this young genius in town darren
aronofsky he had made a movie called pie
and there was this group floating around
by you know uh hubert selwy
jr and darren and based on hubert's book
and it was just
absolutely you know stunning script
brutal just a brutal brutal read and
heartbreaking but
you know something very very special and
you know i fought really hard to be a
part of that film and
you know darren took a a chance on me
and i'll always be
so grateful for that but yeah i remember
going to new york and
living on the street and diving deep
and really getting close to some of the
folks that i met there that
were living similar lives to harry cole
farb
hey what would happen if we went down
they had a cop
are you serious why not what the [ __ ]
are you saying
we supposed to welcome some room clerk
at some hotel and ask him for a
connection
with it you're telling me that you can't
nose out some dope when it's around
[Music]
man we got nothing to lose it's wide
open and if we get there right away
we can name our own price and we can sit
back and be cool and have those [ __ ]
fools come for the streets for us
jennifer connolly one of one of the
greatest and
uh marlin uh one of the funniest and
ellen a legend it was just really
special
we all felt like okay this is an
opportunity to see what
we're made of to push ourselves really
hard and i did go through
really intense body transformation for
the role my thought was i wanted it i
wanted
the character to be in a place of
constant
you know starvation of craving of desire
and food was a great way to do that i
also just from on my own experience and
education
knew that you know it would be a good
physical representation of somebody that
was living in that world at that time
really unique because i think darren
demanded
like eight weeks of rehearsal or
something which is never you never do
you know you're lucky if you rehearse at
all on a movie and
you know i think he was a little
surprised when he thought you know
he was encouraging us all to go deep
when i
went deep i don't think he expected it
to go that far
but it was a beautiful experience
oh no
no she'll come
yeah i don't think there's there's no
method in the world that could
make your arm go away but uh i mean i
guess there is
but yeah i think there was a green you
know there was a blue or green uh
sleeve on it and uh or there was
some kind of a trick i can't remember
but effective i guess
you know um and it was just like that
that
there were stays there were days that
were just full of tears
and pain and other days that were full
of hope and dreams
and hubert selby would always i think he
would say that the book was about
the american dream and how that can be a
drug in and of itself
a harrowing experience i remember almost
every moment of that film it's funny how
some things make such an impact on you
mr nobody mr nobody is kind of my
secret film uh you know most people
never even
heard of it but there was a movie i made
right before that
which maybe we should make a little
special note of called chapter 27
played a guy named mark david chapman
who uh
had the you know distinct
badge of uh taking john lennon's life um
and i gained 67
pounds and it was a character study
about this
you know disturbed and disturbing person
um and very very big physical
transformation
when i look back at it i kind of i wish
maybe someone had stopped me and said
no no no no maybe like 20 pounds is good
maybe get some prosthetics uh but i i
went for it
and it was fascinating how the
that gaining that 60 pounds changed
the way that i walked that changed the
way that i talked
changed the way even that i laughed
certainly i was
unrecognizable i remember running into
darren aronofsky at some
oscar party and i still hadn't shed the
weight
from the film and i walked up to him at
a party and i was face to face with him
and this is a guy who noticed my face
really well
having directed it but he didn't even
recognize me he said
can i help you and i said it's me it's
jared and then he just literally fell
down on the floor
like he fell down he slid down the wall
onto his
onto the floor with this face in his
hands he could not believe that it was
me it was quite
quite a fun party trick but anyway
that's chapter 27 very very very very
challenging uh
dark movie but you know um was it was a
big
step as far as
the transformation and transformative uh
approach to things
and mr nobody it's my european movie it
was made by a really beautiful
team of collaborators in belgium uh but
jacob and dormail was the director
and he's just a terrific talent you know
quite a beautiful
experience really beautiful group of
people
that's a film for for the thinkers out
there the philosophers i think
it's it's a heady one can you tell me
how old you are
oh i'm 34.
i was born february 9th
1975.
who are you i'm mr nobody a man who
doesn't
exist i played the oldest band in the
world
120 year old man 120 something
and uh yeah i play i play you know a
dozen or so versions of the same person
all on you know parallel tracks uh
diverging and crossing and when i played
the old
man i really felt you know kind of at
home in a strange way it was a full
prosthetics piece
i thought they did a really great job as
a team out of berlin
yeah i really got into playing the old
man that was quite
funny and he looked a lot like my
grandfather
so i guess they got it right it was many
many many
hours but and i i wouldn't be able to do
that again because i get
pretty claustrophobic and you know that
was
full head piece i mean that goes on and
you're you're in it you can't pull
it off if you wanted to so
it's uh yeah it makes my palm sweat just
thinking about it
dallas buyers club well it had been
about five or
six years since i made a movie i think
and
then uh i got this script and i was on
tour with 30 seconds to mars at that
point i really was so busy and things
were going so well
you know it was like why am i gonna get
off this
ride right now to go make a film i i
wasn't in any hurry to make a film not
to sound ungrateful but
my brother and i had worked for so many
years
i mean we were signed as a band in 1998
we were making demos and playing music
many many years before that so
you know we had just finally started to
get some traction
i think we started playing uh arenas
uh just a year or two before that all
over the world
and it was just like this impossible
dream
had come true so uh you know firmly
entrenched in that world and
and focusing on that and then this
script comes along and i thought i just
read it i just
knew that it was something special
fell in love with the character and the
opportunity and the challenge
and you know the the
ability to kind of learn new things and
to go on a brand new adventure relax
i don't bite
i guess you're handsome in a texas egg
white trash dumb kind of
get way [ __ ] out of here whatever you
are before i kick you in the
face
you want to play cards
you know for me what i remember are the
people that were involved i remember the
time and the places i remember being in
new orleans for dallas buyers
i remember you know the people that i
met with that
you know helped educate me and guide me
and advise me
and teach me and that support and that
love
i remember all of that as the the most
um you know of course there's a whole
other phase of that movie when it came
out and
you know it was uh well received and
we won awards that's a whole nother
kind of aspect but the making of film
[Music]
was again immersive transformative and
um
you know michelle mark vale just a
really brave filmmaker and i knew
matthew was in a place where he was
doing just
really incredible work so i felt happy
just to be
a small part of it to be honest
okay i'm taking you to the hospital no
no no no
no rayon trust me no
[Music]
you're not gonna die no just trust me
come on
experience that weight loss that kind of
starvation
and that physical and mental tool when
you're playing those roles
yes definitely
i don't know how you do it another way
but
everyone has their own method you know i
have mine other people have theirs
and you know they they to varying
degrees we all have our methodology and
um i kind of shy away from the term
method
actor because it i think has taken on
negative connotations
i always think if it's you know my
approach to acting it's my job
to do the best i can to help contribute
in a meaningful way and
to help tell the story help bring a
character life
to to be a pleasure to work with to be
kind and generous to my other actors
like all of that's part of the same
bucket
and um you know it's different people
just have different approaches and
you know uh i think it's up to everyone
just to do what they're
comfortable doing to contribute in in a
meaningful way
i mean people work so hard on movies you
know directors
writers 20 years that guy had the script
for dallas buyers club
and the producers in the studio the
people that invest the money the crew
you know when you show up you know i
always think wow i
i i this is i better not let anybody
down
i do remember the process though i did
lose so much weight
um people started treating me different
which was
good for the character and interesting
and also
surreal even off the set you know people
i guess i looked like i was
you know really ill or probably looked
like i was dying
you know it was interesting to see how
people would deal with that
um so that was that's something that you
don't
you you can't really imagine you just
have to experience it
suicide squad stepping into the joker
shoes
is like you know it's an incredible
opportunity i guess it's
this generation's version of like
you know taking on a infamous
shakespearean character
lots of people have played the part
before lots of people played it in the
future so you really it's
it's an opportunity to kind of to do
something new
and to explore you know uh challenging
territory
and we had a lot of fun with it um but
it's it's also interesting how this
stuff all takes on a life of its own
uh but i i did i never gave margot
robbie a a dead rat uh that's just
that's not true
i actually they gave her um
you know a lot of i found this place in
toronto that had great
uh vegan cinnamon buns
and that was a very uh common
thing what do we have
here i did everything you said
i helped you ah you
helped me by erasing my mind
what creative memories i had
oh you left me in a black hole of rage
and confusion
without the medicine you practice dr
quinzel
what are you gonna do are you gonna kill
me mr j why
i remember walking the streets of
toronto at night
and you know rehearsing my lines and
going over things
uh and and you know there
there there's a lot of pressure when you
are part of those big movies
you know for not just forget the
character for a second
when you're part of these giant movies
they're
they're inherently come with even uh
maybe more responsibility it feels like
maybe it shouldn't
and that's that's maybe my fault to not
try to filter that out
but um i've done mostly smaller movies i
mean dallas buyers club was a four
million dollar movie
uh you know it's it's an experimental
film in a lot of ways
same with mr nobody it's it was a small
independent
a european film uh so that was like a
step into a whole new world
but it was it was it was a lot of fun
and there was a
just a mutual kind of respect and
support on the set and
you know just the feeling of camaraderie
you know i stayed a little bit separate
because i felt like
my character was a little bit separate
but i really was it was great to always
hear
all the laughter and the camaraderie
that was
you know in abundance on the
blah set all of that
chit chat's gonna get jerked oh my god
and the other thing i loved on that set
was a lot of times i'd play dark i'm in
darker films and i played darker
characters
certainly in requiem you know uh
there wasn't a ton of laughter on the
set probably
but what was fun with the joker was
you know he he said such outlandish
things all the time
i could often hear the crew
like stifling laughter or the camera
which was on the shoulder would be
shaking
because people would be laughing and
that was really fun just to kind of
entertain the troops
and play with with humor uh
and then that that that experience kind
of i i think
you know is something that i carried
with me and
some of the other stuff that i've done
blade runner 2049
ridley scott he played run the original
blade runner
i mean one of my top films
for me just the genius movie i fell in
love with that movie on vhs as a kid and
watched it over and over and
it just it taught me a lot about cinema
and acting and
set design and creativity
i remember getting the call neander
wallace
and i was like okay as soon as i saw
that name on the script i thought wow
this is where do we go from here wes
is amazing uh but i can't believe i got
to be in blaver and i mean for me that's
like
you know just now i know i'm living in a
simulation
for sure yeah just just incredible
to preserve the clay
before we even know what we are
i have these contacts made that were
opaque so i couldn't see
which was actually kind of great because
i didn't have to
get confronted with the problem of you
know uh
acting um like i couldn't see i actually
couldn't see
and i had a really wonderful teacher a
guy named chris
who was who is blind and
uh an amazing
coach and we actually modeled my
eyes in the film after his eyes in real
life and he was just
just a really special person uh he's
just a really special person and
you know uh there's there's a lot of him
in
in that kind of in the physicality that
performance
i have wanted to meet you for so
very long
you are a wonder to me mr deckard
working with harrison ford again a dream
just i couldn't see him
uh but that voice and i remember
reaching out i had to hold his hand for
a minute
and that was great
i know you know something
help me and very
very good things can come to you
you don't have children
do you well i have
millions i'll tell you a quick candidate
from that so we
finished up the scene long shoot day
very intense in this cavernous office
you could hear your
voice at going off the walls and we did
the scene
a bunch of times a bunch of times and
it was my first day on set we're
finished up
and they kind of brought me shuffled me
off to the side the
the a.d did i was standing there alone
and someone comes up to me and wraps
their arms around me and
gives me this huge hug very emotional
hug i'm not sure because i couldn't see
but i felt like
there you know may have been like uh
tears flowing
uh and it was uh harrison ford and
it was really special and beautiful
moment
and you know i think that he
went somewhere really special on that
scene and i was so
happy to be there with him you know as
he was
uh putting such great work on the screen
the little things well a good old albert
sparma i'd be really happy if i saw him
someone dressed up as albert's farmer
for halloween
that would be a fun one right you must
really like my car
i do how's the trunk space
again it was incredibly transformational
it was a different eye color
different nose i had some other
prosthetics i had different teeth
um there was a walk and there was a
different way of speaking
and i really just wanted to bring to
life a character that
that people hadn't spent time with
before and i felt like
you know albert sparma from the name
itself you knew he was someone different
he's an outsider a bit of a dark horse
and
you know i wanted to explore that
territory
and you know just dove in deep
[Music]
how's the trunk space i was so thrilled
to be working with one of my heroes
in uh denzel washington you know the
master of the goat
he is uh just terrific and rami malek
was just phenomenal partner
in this you know i think the three of us
felt like
there was an opportunity here and we all
just jumped in the ring with one another
and
you know it was it was explosive